5 things that men love,
but they will never admit to you.
Number one: when you run up to them with excitement and hug them!
if you haven't seen them all day,
or maybe even have seen them,
but men love to see you get excited for them!
they feel like a man when they can pick you up and embrace you!
number two: whenever you kiss their head / kiss their cheek
men love this!
okay they love affection and they love to feel special
number three
when you wear his clothes.
men love when you wear their baggy T-shirt,
hoodie, or shorts!
they think it's precious.
not only that,
they think that you wanna feel closer to them by wearing their clothes
and it's true! We love to smell their hoodies or shirts that smell like them
Number four: telling them where you actually want to eat okay
men love this!
be honest tell them where you actually want to eat,
instead of turning down every option that he gives you
and then you end up going to the place that you wanted to originally
just be honest
tell them where you wanna eat
men love when you know what you want!
No. 5 playing with their hair or giving them back scratches
men love this
they're not used to pampering themselves,
the only person who touches them is probably you
so whenever you play with their hair or scratch their back
they feel like a happy golden retriever
they love it
and they die for it!
Men love all of these things
and they'll probably never admit it